[Music]
hi yeah thanks it's great to be here
it's a privilege to be speaking to you
today i'm really excited to share with
you my thoughts around web orphan
and why we should start forgetting about
passwords my name
is ben decry i've been a software
engineer now for about 20 years just
over 20 years
and my passion has always been around
security and privacy
one of the things that really excites me
about web often is that
we live in a world nowadays where it's
quite common
to outsource all of the authentication
to
a cloud provider like auth0 who will
allow you to integrate
an sdk with your application and get
login and single sign-on
and multi-factor authentication all
these mechanisms out of the box
but the credentials are all stored in
one place now arguably it's better to
give that to a company who's dedicated
to making sure that it's secure
but web often helps us one step further
by making sure that the credentials
can't actually be
leaked at any point because they exist
on these tiny little
devices or in in your phones or on your
laptops
so the hardware authenticators become
the mechanism that uh prove
your credentials rather than remembering
a password for example
so i think web often is uh the future of
web ortho
is that it's going to make uh lives as
users a lot easier and our lives as
developers
and uh even the infrastructure side of
things
are a lot less stressful so it can only
be a good thing
before we have a look in depth at what
web author is and how it works
let's look at passwords and other
credentials let's look at the
characteristics that we look for in sets
of credentials and work out
where they sit how they relate to each
other and what the pros and cons of each
are
so when i look at a set of credentials
there are three main
groups of characteristics that i look at
to work out whether or not i think
it's a good performing a well-performing
credential set
the first thing is is it easy to use is
it easy to remember
is it going to be hard for somebody else
to guess or in the case of where it's
not something that's guessable
can can it be easily cloned the second
thing
is how easy is it to change if somebody
does manage to guess my password for
example how easy can i change it if
somebody manages to get access to my
phone
how easily can i change it a change
mechanism is really important
but if it's really easy to remember and
hard to guess and really easy to change
those two by themselves don't help if
they're all so easy to intercept so
obviously we want
any credential mechanism to be hard to
intercept so if it's hard to intercept
if it's easy to change and if it's easy
to remember and how to guess then it's a
good set of credentials
let's have a look at some of these
credentials and see how they stack up
i'm going to use a very non-scientific
mechanism here
basically to plonk onto a graph
the performance that i think that each
of these credential types have
with the characteristics that we've just
looked at i'm basically going to say
that they perform really well really
badly or somewhere in the middle is it a
bit of a gray area situation
and i've mentioned passwords already
let's start there because that's a
credential mechanism that we're all
familiar with
usually tied with a username or an email
address or something a password is
something we have to remember
which means that they're increasingly or
significantly hard to use in terms of
the the remembering side of things
they're also
somewhat easy to guess in so far that as
if i have a password that's easy for me
to remember then it's either going to be
one of
uh many passwords that are quite common
or the
uh the length of the password is going
to be such that a computer could
iterate through and do a brute force
attack and get to it relatively quickly
the easier it is for me to remember a
password the easier it is for a computer
or a human
to generate or guess that password
the um the ease of change though
is something that passwords are probably
the best at
which is not necessarily a saving grace
for passwords it's just a fact
that a password is basically is stored
in a database or in some kind of storage
mechanism somewhere
ideally it's going to be hashed so that
it can't be reverse engineered from the
hash
but to change a password just requires
you to prove your identity
and then provide a new password which
will then get hashed using the same
mechanism and stored in the database
table
so it's basically it's the hash and
database update and that's all that's
technically required
to perform a password change so changing
a password really easy
intercept is i'm going to put it
slightly
down towards the negative side of the
gray area
it's becoming a lot harder to intercept
because nowadays we're a lot more
focused on
https everywhere it's more common to
find even your standard blog that
doesn't even require you to log in
to view it will still be over https and
there are various other reasons why we
run
all our websites over https in terms of
security and privacy and tracking and
various other things
but it does mean that when the passwords
are in transit when we're sending
details from the browser to a server
they're a lot more secure already than
they might have been in the past where
it was possibly commonplace for less
uh security strict web applications
to to encrypt those passwords in transit
but we still have an issue
when it's at rest or before it's even
sent so if there's a malicious
plugin in your browser or there's a
cross-site scripting attack in in the
application
then the password could be intercepted
before it's even sent to the server
and once it's at the server if it's not
hashed properly or there's a
disgruntled employee who leaks the data
or a hacker who gets in and leaks the
data
there are all sorts of ways the
passwords can be leaked and we're all
probably familiar with the have our
being pwned website
which is run by a fellow australian
basically a database of a whole lot of
large data breaches and passwords that
have been leaked
so that people are able to find out
whether or not they've been affected by
this but the pure existence of have i
been pwned
points to the fact that passwords are
really are
not a very secure credential mechanism
for us to use nowadays
so we tend to layer it let's have a look
at a different kind of credential that
we can use
the sms's we've mentioned sms's and
emails
a little already the um they're
basically in the same kind of bucket
it's a message that gets sent to you
somehow and you can act on that message
maybe you get sent a six-digit code or a
four-digit code or
a password of some sort of one-time
password or maybe it's a link that you
click on
and that link will die once you've
clicked on it but it'll verify
that you have access to the device or
the email account that that message was
sent
to so in terms of remembering it really
it's quite easy to remember in fact
there is nothing to remember
you need to have your phone on you or
access to your email account but then
that one time code is something you type
in or the link is something you click
it's ideally one time so nobody else can
then use it in the future
but there's nothing actually to remember
it's also going to be quite hard to
guess because it's going to be random
code each time
and the the url is going to be
randomized each time
ideally so in terms of hard to guess
easy to remember
scores pretty highly changing is
about as easy as a password well it may
be a little harder essentially it's just
an email address or a phone number in a
database field
but we need as developers when we're
looking at the security side of things
to take extra precautions when changing
a password uh when changing an email
address
rather or an sms in that we need to
make sure that if they change their
phone number for example
we send the user a message to the new
phone to make sure they actually have
access to it
we might also want to send a message
their old phone number saying hey
somebody's just changed your phone
number
so that if it was somebody who's not
supposed to be changing this that the
original users made aware of it and the
same counts for emails as well if we're
changing
our email or our phone numbers or any
kind of communication endpoints
and mechanisms for the website to get in
touch with us
we need to both verify that we have
access to the new account
and the old account needs to be told
that the change has been made
in terms of intercept it's going to be
harder to intercept than a password
but there is still a number of
vulnerabilities so i'm not going to put
it into the green area
there are issues with with email
not with email itself per se but if
somebody does have access to email
then they have access to pretty much any
site that uses email as a password reset
mechanism so that puts us into a little
bit of a dangerous territory
when it comes to sms's the s7 protocol
which is the
mechanism used by the mobile carriers
around the world to make sure that sms's
get delivered
to between networks the the protocol
itself
has a couple of vulnerabilities which
are not necessarily easy to perform
but they do allow somebody for example
to say hey i want to
intercept an sms going to ben so i know
ben's mobile number i'm going to put in
an s7
network attack to have any messages sent
to ben come to me instead and in fact
maybe you could even set it to send ben
uh a different response or still the
same response so there's nothing out of
the ordinary
but in steps are possible so in this
case it's
a targeted attack they have to
specifically say we want to attack that
phone number or in case of an email
they'd have to
attack a certain email address unless
the passwords come up in a password
leak such as through have i been phoned
so there are a number of issues but
certainly
intercepts are harder than pure
passwords so i've scored it slightly
higher you can probably see that it's
slightly more towards the green
area there slapping in the middle of the
gray area
then we've got voice or biometrics maybe
it's a fingerprint
the advantage with these uh
types of credentials the biometric
credentials is
i don't remember the last time i left
home without my fingerprint
or without my voice obviously there are
things that can change them
and from using them as a pure credential
mechanism or as a sole
credential mechanism my fingerprint can
get damaged if i'm
doing woodwork my voice can get damaged
if i uh i'm singing a lot not that i
sing very much but maybe i've
had a cult and my voice has changed so
there are various things that can change
um the the the credential
essentially but it's not really
something i have to remember so in terms
of easy to remember
um hard to to clone or how to emulate
i'm going to score it pretty highly in
terms of changing however
it's not only possible i can't change my
fingerprint i do have
10 fingerprints so i can definitely i
can technically change which fingerprint
i use to authenticate nine times but
then i'm out of fingers
i i can't i can't go beyond that also
once one fingerprint has been leaked i
need to make sure that it's never used
anywhere else because i can't change i
can't invalidate this fingerprint
if somebody has a fingerprint and i'll
talk about how that could happen
in a second uh it we can't change it i
can't change my voice it changes
slightly over time
that's a different issue but i i can't
say
look my voice has been compromised i
need a different one but that's not
possible
in terms of intercept i'm scoring it
quite highly but it's not quite in the
green area
because there are a couple of little
issues we know
nowadays and you might have seen it
yourselves some of these videos with a
side and side video where there's
some general member of the public
talking and then
on the other side there's an
artificially intelligently created
video of let's say for example barack
obama and it's his face
his lips are moving in time to the words
and the words are coming out in his
voice and that's all computer generated
using artificial intelligence
based on what this person over here is
saying so technically it's possible
to emulate voice technically it's
possible to
also emulate fingerprints there's
another uh story where somebody was able
to take
a high resolution photo of fingerprint
on a glass
and taking that high resolution photo
into a
3d rendering software turning into a 3d
model and then printing it with 3d
printer using a material
that was accepted by the fingerprint
scanner as skin they were able to unlock
a mechanism using
a cloned fingerprint so it's technically
possible but in both of these cases
they are again targeted attacks like the
sms situation
you have to you can only emulate one
voice at a time you can't just break all
voices
you have to find the fingerprint that
you need to unlock so the targeted
attacks
the intercept is uh performs well in
terms of
it's hard to intercept but it is still
possible and we need to remember that
and you've probably noticed that there
are three main characteristics here of
password types and we call this
multi-factor authentication
we have passwords which is something
that you know something in your head
we have sms's or emails which is
something you have you have access to
the email account or you have the
sim card that's in your phone and then
we've got voice and fingerprint
which is something that you are it's a
biometric authentication mechanism
so in order to make users more secure
we now tend to look towards multi-factor
authentication where we need at least
two possibly three of these
characteristics you can't have two
password types or two somethings you
know
you have to have one from each of these
three columns and they could be things
like a pin number
an access card and a client certificate
in the browser but having
a notebook client certificate is
something you you um
you ah it's actually something you have
but you could have voice for example
still
so getting multiples of these factors
make us more secure
and the downside to that though is that
we're making it less convenient for
people to log in we're putting extra
layers of security in
which makes convenience harder and
people are going to be slightly more
annoyed at having to log in
so we have to to balance the user
experience journey here
with proving who we are as users so what
you'll find is that maybe
to access the system in the first place
you just need a username and password
and that'll get you in
you can see your dashboard perhaps if
it's internet banking for example
you can see your statements but if you
want to do a transfer then
you've got to give it a second factor of
authentication maybe they'll send you a
code
via sms or maybe if it's a
physical presence you're trying to log
into you'll need to use your fingerprint
scanner
to to access whatever it is you're
trying to get to so we can do this
step-up authentication
where higher levels of authentication
required for more sensitive actions that
we want to take
let's uh consider not using passwords or
anything that you know
at all and you might have heard of the
term password list this is where we get
rid of
the need to remember things obviously
you need to remember your phone or your
hardware authenticator
but the need to remember things in your
brain in terms of what was my password
when did i change it these these kind of
things are thrown out when we look at
passwordless
and if we look at just things that we
are and things that we have we can get
passwordless authentication
which is a lot more convenient people
that need to remember things if you're
using a different computer and you have
a password manager you don't need access
to your password manager anymore
so we're making it easier for people to
log in but now we're also
reducing the number of factors that we
can use so if we go purely passwordless
convenience is high we've still got good
levels of authentication
and credential checking but we've lost
one of the factors that we can use so
technically
maybe you could consider that it's
getting slightly weaker for the the sake
of slightly more
uh convenience or ease of use for our
users
so let's bring in the fido security key
now and that's the things like these
little
usb devices or your mobile phones that
have a hardware authenticator built in
these are what web author uses for
authentication
the advantage with these is that they
have a public private key on board
which means that the credentials are
always stored
or the the mechanism for identifying
yourself is
is contained within the key itself this
makes it really easy to to use a really
hard to guess
the public private keypad the only way
of generating a signature
of a payload and we'll look into the
technicalities of how we're both
works in a minute but the the ability to
clone
a public private key pair is
mathematically improbable
i'm not going to say it's impossible
there's probably some minuscule
probability that somebody somewhere
might be able to do this
but again it would have to be a targeted
attack it's going to take a huge amount
of computing resources
so we can essentially call it impossible
for most intents and purposes
it's impossible to clone a public
private key pair for the purposes
of breaking a fido security key signing
mechanism
in terms of changing it's about as easy
to change as changing your phone number
or your email address on a website
you just register a new fido security
key with the web application you're
trying to log into
and if you need to you can deregister
the old one often
you might find that it's useful for your
users to have multiple keys anyway
because then if they lose one they've
got a backup maybe they have one in
their pocket or in their on their
keychain
and one in a safe somewhere just in case
something goes wrong
and that way they can use either of them
to log in and
they they have that backup mechanism
because the
the ability to recreate like i say the
public private key pair is so
mathematically improbable
they lost their key they've lost their
credential mechanism
in terms of intercept again really high
and there's an additional thing that i'm
going to add on
like i say generating a public private
key pair or cloning it is so improbable
that you're not going to be able to
clone the
the um the public private key pair
similarly when
the the signed challenges which we'll
look at in a second and the keys are
passed around
the public key is the only one that ever
leaves the the
the fighter security key so public keys
are public
it doesn't matter if they're leaked and
the signed challenge is only good for
one request anyway
so intercept even if you could intercept
the data
it doesn't matter because it's a single
purpose single use and it can't be used
against
the the wrong web application you're
trying to log into and this is a really
important
additional feature is that it eliminates
phishing attempts
you might find we'll have a look at what
fishing phishing actually
how it works in a second but you might
find that if you're
if you provide credentials to the wrong
application then
obviously that malicious user is going
to be able to use that data
to although the credentials to log in as
you um phishing is
is how that works let's have a look at
that in fact
so you've got a user uh let's say this
is you trying to
uh have a lovely uh day watching
videos at uh jsconf korea
and you get an sms or you get an email
at some point and i had one of these
emails just the other day
uh it was from google and they said
you've run out of cloud
storage we're not able to back up your
device anymore click here to upgrade
your
your account to get more storage let's
say you got one of those but it wasn't
actually from google let's say it was
from
let's say i was trying to get into your
google account i sent you the
the message but it actually took you to
a website that looks very much like
google
and uh to your brain it felt like you're
logging into google and all the
messaging felt right so you just clicked
on it and you get this login page
and you provide your actual credentials
to this website but your brain doesn't
notice that the domain is actually
slightly different
so you provide these credentials and the
first thing i'm going to do as an
attacker is i'm going to send you
to a fake success page i could send you
to the actual google website and the
likelihood is if you're a google user
because you logged in then you're
probably actually logged in already so
you'd
you'd get to the google website after i
redirect you there and it would look
like you'd
successfully logged in but there's a
reason i'm using a fake success page
we'll come back to that in a second
meanwhile you've sent your actual google
credentials to me
or more likely to a script that i've got
running somewhere and that script is
then going to take those credentials and
pass them to the google server and say
hey i want to log in
with this username and password to see
whether or not they work and in an ideal
situation what happens
is i get a 200 confirmed it's okay
yes you're logged in and i i now have
access to your google account i can
change your credentials and hijack your
account or i could use your account
for fake reviews or whatever it is that
i want to do with your
your google details i now have your
credentials now let's go back to the
fake success page for a second
you might be aware that if i did try to
log into your google account then
google's probably going to notice and
all of the larger websites and any of
the the websites out there that
um will check where you're logging in
from will alert you
if you're logging in from a system that
has not been recognized so you might get
a
message on the browser if if you're
doing this legitimately saying hey
it looks like you're logging in from a
new device or from a new country
we're going to send you an sms please
enter your code in here
to verify that you are who you say you
are this is the step of authentication
that we were talking about before
or maybe it's a push notification we're
sending a push notification hit the yes
button
and then we'll log you in so if that
happens to me while i'm trying to log in
as you
then if you get the push notification
you hit yes i'm logged in
if you get the sms where do you put the
code
so if i give you a fake success page
that says hey i need this code you type
your code in
then i have your code i can use that to
log in and the likelihood is
if in your brain you think you're
logging into the real google website and
you get the notification
saying hey it looks like somebody's
trying to log into your google account
you're going to hit yes without noticing
that down at the bottom it says
you're logging in from melbourne
australia which is me not you
so basically what phishing is is the
ability to trick somebody
to provide their credentials into a fake
login page
let's have a look at how web orphans
registration and login process work now
and how they stop the fake login page
scenario or phishing
from happening so let's say this is you
and you're trying to log into my website
you go to your browser you type in url
from our website you hit the register
button and you say i want to create a
new account
my name is susan so you provide the
username susan to my server my server
says hey it looks like you're trying to
create a new account
using fido or using web author so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to return
to you or rather to your browser
i'm going to send you a challenge and
this is some randomly generated code
some some text some some data that i
require a
signed response for let's have a look
how that signature happens
so the data gets sent to the browser the
browser then uses the
navigator.credentials api which is the
api available in the newer browsers to
enable web often
and this navigator credentials api has
two methods on it the first one that
we're going to look at is the creator
has a number of methods but the first
one we'll look at is the create method
and into it we pass the challenge that
got sent from the server and also we
pass in the web origin so if you're
looking at google.com
it'll say google.com if you're looking
at gw0gl3.com
it'll have that in the web origin so
each key pair is now locked into the
domain
and no matter how confused your brain
might be your browser is never going to
get confused about the web origin that
gets sent to
the uh the web as part of the web author
and login process
so that web origin is used by the the
security key
to generate a new public private key
pair locked to that web origin
and then it'll take the challenge that
it received as well and it'll use the
private key
to sign the challenge and then we'll
return just that signed challenge
and the public key back to the browser
the private key gets stored
on the security key on the actual device
the only the public key gets sent back
to the browser
along with a public key identifier or a
key pair identifier
and the signed challenge the browser
doesn't do anything with this other than
send it straight onto the server
so when susan has created her account
the final response to the server
includes the the private or the public
key rather the public key id
and the signed challenge so my server
can now say hey i know that susan tried
to create an account
and i know that i sent her browser this
challenge and i've just received this
signed challenge in return which i can
verify
is a assigned version of the original
challenge
and it's also been signed with the key
pair that's associated with this public
key that's come back
so essentially this is now in effect my
my password it's it's the way that i
verify that susan is the person who's
logging in next time
so into my database i'll store susan's
username the
public key and the public key id they're
the three bits of information that i
need to store
so now susan comes back and she wants to
log in she's got an account already
and she says hey my username is susan i
want to log in and my server is now
going to say well i know that there is a
user called susan already and in fact
susan's got this
public private key pair id that i'm i'm
aware of so i'm not going to send back
to susan's browser
the the um the challenge and also
the id of the public private key pair
that i expect
her to sign this challenge with and
return back to me so i need to make sure
that she has
the same key available to her that was
used when she registered her account
so we now call the the get method on the
navigator.credentials api
and into that again we pass the
challenge we pass the web origin and we
also pass in
the id this time so the hardware
authenticator
can now pull out the public private key
pair rather the private key associated
with that id
they can use that private key to sign
the challenge that got sent in
and then return just that signed
challenge signed challenge goes back to
the browser
and the browser then returns that signed
challenge back to the server
so in logging in susan told me her
username i sent a challenge plus an id
that id referenced the public private
key pair that was used to sign the
challenge which is then returned back to
the server
and i can verify that the assigned
challenge that came back
is a signed version of the challenge
that i sent for the login process which
will be different to the one that was
used for the registration process
but i can also verify that it was signed
with a key pair that matches the
public key that i have on record already
so i'm not updating that i'm using
the previously stored public key to
verify
that the signature was generated by the
same device
so it's essentially proving that the
person who's logged in has access to the
hardware authenticator
which in the case of some hardware
authenticators might just prove
that they have possession but in the
case of
one's way like their pixel 2 where you
have the fingerprint reader on the back
or maybe the macbook pro where you need
to touch the fingerprint
scanner to activate the hardware
authenticator it also proves
who's there because while you don't know
what the fingerprint is you know that it
was the same
uh person who was able to unlock the key
the first time
so i hope that's given you a bit of a an
insight into how web authent works how
the flow works
how we manage to eliminate phishing
attacks to the
tying of the web origin to the public
private key
and how it makes us as developers more
secure the applications we develop more
secure insofar as we don't have to store
credentials
on in our databases anymore we're
actually just storing
a public key which we can use to verify
future signatures
generated by the the hardware
authenticators that are used
in the web author login flow
i'm going to be sticking around after
this for q a i'm more than happy to take
any questions and i'd also love to show
you a demo using webworth.me which is a
website
written by one of my colleagues i'm also
available
on twitter my dms are open here's my
email address
i'd love for you to get in contact with
me afterwards connect with me via
linkedin
i'd love to hear your stories about the
kinds of
problems you're trying to solve and just
to generally connect
thank you for your time and i'll talk to
you in the q a thanks